côté interactif les écrans tout ça et
bah c'est plutôt plaisant en fait ça
change des musées c'est intéressant
la mise en scène et la scénographie ou
permet de resituer personnage dans
l'histoire et puis au delà de toute
récupération politique
ces endroits qui ont été restaurées
magnifiquement les voûtes vraiment les
lieux sont impressionnants et son
superbe
oui oui ça ça nous a beaucoup plu on va
dire que j'étais venu un peu en curieux
quand je connaissais comme tout le monde
de l'histoire de jeanne d'arc
mais je pense que là j'ai découvert au
delà de l'histoire
une petit soupçon de rêve un petit peu
d'imaginaire et puis une réalité ça
prend de la chaire cette histoire